[Musique]
la vérité sur la réunion avant 1946 un
titre ambitieux vous invite à ouvrir les
portes des archives départementales des
nouveaux documents d'archivés couvre que
notre île a connu elle aussi ses
sultanat ces royaumes ces dynasties ces
concessions étrangères et ses ruines
antiques et ses cordes de lyon sauvage
pas de cadres pas de gens pour cette un
cyclo pdi du continent réunionnais qui
est la dernière exposition financée par
le département entre sérieux et dérision
d'un discours enflammé
l'auteur annonce le second degré comme
fil conducteur c'est une fiction global
je crois que tous tout le tout les gens
qui ont déjà regardé game of thrones ou
qui ont joué à un jeu vidéo ont eu envie
de recréer un monde dans un monde qui
connaissent et de l'essai de ce
laisser-aller de rêver à tout ça même si
effectivement à chaque fois derrière il
ya des faits historiques réels
qui sont mélangés mais c'est un voile à
son gros créer un monde simplement à la
réunion qui le dit
[Musique]
vous avez ici
la visite commence dans cette nouvelle
géographie de notre île un paradoxe dans
ce sanctuaire de la vérité historique de
l'art de manuel kangoo dans cette
exposition c'est d'être en permanence
sur le fil de la vraisemblance il faut
que ce soit imaginez mais en même temps
qu'on ait l'impression de reconnaître
des choses qu'on a connu toute la
géographie est absolument authentiques
si on accepte de mettre la carte de la
réunion à l'envers lara patang les
dynasties qui font sourire ou encore des
seigneurs qui font rêver tous semble
bluffé et débuts en fait quand je suis
rentré je pensais que c'était sérieux
mais
oui je vous le dis comme un problème il
faut appeler quelqu'un la réaction est
toujours c'était très surprenant en fait
c'est tout ça que ces restes saisie et
puis on essaye de repenser aux propos
c'est important pour destination ne pas
uniquement cantonnée de ces deux cas la
haskala et de sa tribu et d'autres
choses en fait pourquoi pas la
créativité pourquoi pas l'artistique et
pouvoir aujourd'hui par les deux mythes
de légende des choses qui n'existent pas
fait beaucoup de bien
ou bien parce que notre jeune pression
de
bien que le nord sait bien que c'est la
balle au centre connaît tout petit dans
le sens bien et rien verser les valeurs
dire effectivement tenue est un
continent et que le sens du monde et ici
ça fait beaucoup de bien
donc c'est notre rôle que de laisser les
et les créateurs dirige aux autres moi
qui ne trompent souvent dire aux gens
libérer la pensée libérer la créativité
et venez voir ce que peut donner la
création lorsqu'elle est aussi libre et
aussi impertinente cette réunion à
l'envers qui fait circuler les idées ne
laisse pas indifférent à la fin de la
visite tout semble partager leurs
perceptions une exposition gratuite a
exploré jusqu'à la fin de l'année
[Musique]